it's always sad to watch your favorite
characters shuffle off this mortal coil
but it's even worse for the actors
involved who often have to film these
emotionally difficult scenes over and
over again it's no wonder then that
actors often try to lighten the mood by
goofing off right as their character is
kicking the bucket here's a look at some
unexpected bloopers during death scenes
inglorious basterds
sally manky was an Academy Award
nominated film editor who worked on
nearly all of Quentin Tarantino's films
until she passed away in 2010 while
working with men key actors and crew
members and Tarantino's films would
leave friendly messages for her while
shooting which she discovered months
later in the editing Bay like this bit
from inglourious basterds actor til
Schweiger dracula dead and loving it Mel
Brooks virtually created the movie
parody genre making full-length parodies
of entire film genres like Blazing
Saddles
Spaceballs and Dracula dead and loving
it in one scene a pair of vampire
hunters played by Brooks and Steven
Weber needed the steak of vampire named
Lucy Webber barely held it together as
the scene plays out a little more
vigorously than he expected
oh my god
The Avengers all true fanboys and
fangirls shed a tear at the shocking
loss of SHIELD agent Phil Coulson and
marvel's blockbuster The Avengers but
nobody took it quite as hard as Cobie
Smulders whose agent Maria Hill simply
expressed what everyone of us was
feeling in that dreadful moment
[Music]
and she didn't stop there
shall I be avenged you will be avenged I
will get the adventures and you all will
be avenged Colton
jaws as grizzled old Quinton jaws Robert
Shaw got to have a spectacular gruesome
and memorable farewell the cast and crew
probably had no idea the scene would go
down in the annals of movie history
because to Shaw it was downright
hilarious
thanks to just a little too much big
blood calling Mel Brooks guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 making movies is tough
work with shooting days regularly
lasting more than 14 hours as crews
prepare sets lighting props and
practical effects rigs that means a lot
of tired actors as Michael Rooker proved
in the scene from guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 since he was playing the
deceased yondu all he had to do was lie
there while his co-stars delivered a
heartfelt eulogy over his body but it
turned out to be just a little too
comfortable sometimes it's right there
by your side all along and you don't
even know it
even Drax couldn't wake him
Merlin oh and Mackin portrayed Sir
Gawain in the long-running British
series Merlin right up until the
character was laid low by treachery the
once-mighty Gwaine expired in the arms
of his friend Percival played by Tom
hopper while sadly lamenting his failure
to stop the bad guys or at least it
should have been sad but Hopper
apparently took it a little differently
[Laughter]
the interview in Seth Rogen and James
Franco's controversial 2014 comedy the
interview the duo played an American
talk show producer and host sent to
North Korea on a mission to assassinate
the nation's leader Kim Jong moon along
the way Robin's character got into a
fight to the finish with a North Korean
agent
but as this blooper shows the two actors
weren't exactly treating it like a
moment where life hangs in the balance
Game of Thrones when Jon Snow was
assassinated on Game of Thrones by his
own men at the end of season 5 it was
one of the most shocking moments ever on
the HBO fantasy series so with the red
witch be able to bring him back to life
during season 6 thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]